I THINK THE NOTION THAT FISA WAS
ABUSED HERE IS NONSENSE.
>> SEAN: NONSENSE.
HERE WITH REACTION IS LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
MERRY CHRISTMAS TO YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> SEAN: I READ SOMETHING
INFAMOUS ON THIS SHOW, GRASSLEY
GRAHAM MEMO.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH IT, BUT IF ANY PART OF THE
STEEL DOSSIER WAS USED, WHEN
PUSH COMES TO SHOVE, HE SAID I
DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF IT IS TRUE.
THERE WERE MULTIPLE WARNINGS
GIVEN TO THE FBI, YOU CAN'T
TRUST STEEL HAS AN AGENDA.
HILLARY PAID FOR IT AND IT'S
UNVERIFIED.
IF ANY OF NO DOSSIER WAS USED,
WOULDN'T THAT BE --
[INAUDIBLE]
>> MONDAY NIGHT, MAYBE I'LL BE
ON YOUR SHOW, PLAY THAT CLIP.
>> SEAN: MONDAY NIGHT.
>> PLAY THAT CLIP AND LETS PLAY
THAT CLIP TO WHAT HOROWITZ IS
SAYING ABOUT THE FISA WARRANT
PROCESS AND THE DAY OF RECKONING
IS HERE.
I HAVEN'T BEEN BRIEFED ABOUT THE
DETAILS BUT I BELIEVE IT SHOWS
THE SYSTEM COMPLETELY OFF THE
RAILS FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME,
AND THAT YOU REALLY HAVE TO HATE
TRUMP NOT TO BE UPSET BY WHAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
THE FBI DID AND THERE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT THEY DID, I BELIEVE,
THAT ARE DANGEROUS TO DEMOCRACY.
>> SEAN: LET ME ASK YOU, IF I
HAD A SUBPOENA FOR MY EMAILS,
AND I DECIDE I'M GOING TO DELETE
33,000, AND THEN I'M GOING TO
USE SOMETHING CALLED BLEACH PIT
NOBODY HAD EVER HEARD OF IT, TO
WIPE THE SERVER CLEAN, DO YOU
THINK I WOULD PROBABLY, LIKELY,
BROUGHT UP ON CHARGES OF
OBSTRUCTION?
>> YOU MIGHT NOT BE ON THE
HOWARD STERN SHOW.
UNLESS HE DOES --
>> SEAN: YOU SOLD YOUR SOUL,
SENATOR.
>> THE BOTTOM LINE IS, I THINK
THE FISA WARRANT PROCESS, I'M
LOOKING TO THE COURT.
ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> SEAN: MEANING THE FISA COURT.
>> YES.
I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW THAT IF
IT'S AS BAD AS I THINK IT IS I
EXPECT THE COURT TO MAKE SURE IT
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN P. THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION WAS THE SHAM THAT
I THINK IT IS, WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN BY
CREATING RULES.
I WANT TO KNOW, DID OBAMA KNOW?
DID OBAMA KNOW THAT PRESIDENT
CANDIDATE TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN WAS
BEING SURVEYED BY OUR
GOVERNMENT?
IF YOU REALLY BELIEVE CARTER
PAGE WAS WORKING FOR THE
RUSSIANS WHY DIDN'T YOU TELL
PRESIDENT TRUMP SO HE COULD DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT-LIKE THEY
TOLD FEINSTEIN.
>> SEAN: YOU CAN'T HAVE AN --
>> I DON'T BELIEVE YOU CAN HAVE
ONE ON THE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
FOR PRESIDENT WITHOUT IT GOING
UP THAT HIGH.
JUST THINK OF WHAT HAPPENED.
IN 2016, THE REPUBLICAN NOMINEE
FOR PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, PEOPLE THAT WERE
ASSOCIATED WITH HIS CAMPAIGN,
WERE SURVEYED BY THE GOVERNMENT.
THE GOAL OF A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION IS TO PROTECT
PEOPLE TO LET DIANE FEINSTEIN
KNOW THAT THIS GUY THAT WE THINK
MAY BE WORKING FOR THE CHINESE,
THEY TALKED ABOUT HILLARY, THEY
FOLLOWED THESE GUYS FOR MONTHS,
MULTIPLE WARRANTS WERE REISSUED,
BASED ON THE DOSSIER PAID FOR BY
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT
FOOTNOTED -- THERE IS A FOOTNOTE
THAT I'M GOING TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT, IN THE FISA APPLICATION,
A LOT.
>> SEAN: AT THE TOP OF THE FISA
WARRANT APPLICATION, DOESN'T IT
SAY VERIFIED?
>> RIGHT.
>> SEAN: OKAY.
IF IT'S UNVERIFIABLE AND YOU USE
THE INFORMATION, THAT'S A
PROBLEM.
WALK US THROUGH, MICHAEL
HOROWITZ' REPORT ON MONDAY.
HE'S BEFORE YOUR COMMITTEE ON
WEDNESDAY.
NOW, IS HE GOING TO HAVE A
CHANCE TO REALLY LAY OUT THE
CASE?
HOW MUCH TIME WILL YOU GIVE HIM?
>> ALL THE TIME HE NEEDS.
HERE'S THE DEAL.
THE REPORT COMES OUT MONDAY BUT
YOU REALLY WON'T UNDERSTAND IT
UNTIL HE TESTIFIES WEDNESDAY.
HE'S GOT TO PUT IT IN CONTEXT.
HE'S GOT TO TELL YOU WHAT IS IN
THERE AND HOW ONE THING CONNECTS
TO THE OTHER.
HE'LL HAVE ALL THE TIME HE
NEEDS.
I'LL HAVE TIME TO ASK HIM
QUESTIONS.
I'M GOING TO BASICALLY GO
THROUGH THE FISA WARRANT
PROCESS.
WHAT HE FOUND, AND ASK HIM, IS
THIS DEFRAUDING THE COURT?
WAS THE COURT MISTREATED?
THE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION, VERY LOW STANDARD
OPEN ONE, ARE YOU OKAY WITH
THIS?
SHOULD EVERY POLITICIAN IN
AMERICA BE WORRIED?
I THINK THE ANSWER IS GOING TO
BE YES BECAUSE IF THEY CAN
SURVEY OUR CAMPAIGNS, AND NEVER
TELL US ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE
DOING, THEN THAT REALLY TRULY IS
SPYING.
>> SEAN: BIG WEEK NEXT WEEK.
I'VE BEEN WAITING.